[Music]
in grand theft aro news arrow Holly
stole an airplane submitted by love from
Sudan oh oh I could take her to BB well
I met a fan from Sudan when I was in
Turkey
oh that's on all of us huh
damn man exactly I'm travelling to all
those Muslim countries on an airport
employee stole a plane and flew it for
an hour before crashing he passed away
right so we can make fun we can injure
maybe that was his last Joyride maybe he
wanted to kill himself you [ __ ]
deserve this audio of the sky dude he
died doing what he loves stealing
flying's doing yeah I like that so he
was a ground service agent at Seattle
Tacoma International Airport
aka CTEK maybe that was his dream is
like he always sees the airplanes fly
but he never gets to fly the airplane
he's a good man sweeping the ground all
the pilots like he'll never fly yeah the
[ __ ] out of here
paperboy what does a Ground Service
agent throws a lug it and [ __ ] your [ __ ]
up like this we've seen them there's
time for like they go oh don't worry sir
uh what we'll put it away for you we're
sitting in Wadena and I see this boy
just like with this [ __ ] thing huh
it's [ __ ] chucking that [ __ ] even if
this is [ __ ] brat fragile they just
take it and just [ __ ] just suppress
you want to subscribe it's fragile it's
like it's like the beginning of [ __ ]
hate stories kicking the package down
the hallway it's like damn dude yeah let
me go extra hole it's not if the energy
efficient for you to make exert all this
force while you use my baggage please
maybe it's like you or they have to go
little [ __ ] to like
[ __ ] that's how Steve is Hades to like
yell and curse at items in order to lift
them that's very true
you get in the zone to move [ __ ] I did
yeah and then he lifts the couch
that's dough I'm never gonna happy move
it's fun sounds too intense for me dude
are you really being the cat's eye the
corner I just call more people to help
move I don't want to touch anything I
don't even want to be there can you guys
help me move cool let me know what you
guys are done and they're like hey man
where are you you're like oh I'm not
coming yes this guy I'm gonna play audio
on the airplane crashing keep an eye on
the face because you could see the plane
actually go upside down he was busting
tricks he was an aerial was he trying to
or he just lost control he was trying to
Oh seems like he was trying to act if
knows he was trying to he wanted to die
he just wanted one last Joyride you
would do that to everybody would try
yeah if I knew I was gonna die anyway
yeah he was like 29 I'd steal a plane in
does this will have any flight
experience he does video games like real
ones so this is what really happens he
plays GTA 5 and where you can actually
steal the planes from LAX he's always
stealing planes always yeah well he did
he actually mentioned that he was like
well I was a little bit of experience I
played a little bit of a game video game
something like that so the point is he
said that he knew how to fly because of
video game I have experience from the
movies it's pretty easy there's
literally five clicks and then they
would scrap this thing it made slowly
and then it goes up you also have to
release the brake but as you know you
have to pull it back like this depends
some most plays that I have experience
with you know it's a no time oh and you
got a quick you're fast action man
there's a lot of [ __ ] buttons don't
like the buttons go past pilots head
according to Bart you only need to worry
about five boards right and yours
buttons like back here like I don't even
know how they [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
to people yeah it could someone could
stand up because have you ever seen I
want to be the clicker the buttons go
all the way to the top I thought I want
to be the copilot who just says
beautiful day to day because that's part
of the checklist you have to say
beautiful day to day before you too
before you take off
everybody knows that that's why this
pilot lingo wait is there a video of it
yeah a lot of people I care about me oh
[ __ ] it's gonna disappoint them to hear
that I did this I was also he was going
he wanted to commit suicide
yeah yeah sounds suicidal well he did
all the dimensions it was like well I'm
probably gonna spend life in prison
because of this huh like when he was
talking to the control well so he didn't
he was gonna die he thought he was just
gonna go to jail controls everything he
probably picked dying over life in
prison
Oh like he just said that he didn't
really know until now that he was like
had some screws loose yeah he would have
not gone life in prison for that he
doesn't know the law did can all agree
were they like yeah man you're going
away a long long time like were they
building it or were they no yeah they
were just like no that's the worst
suicide what does that guys call the
position negotiator
oh yeah that's like the worse he's like
yeah buddy a long time you're not gonna
ever see freedom if I told me you better
unclick those five buttons and pull it
back slowly that's the same yeah so he
was married he was married hmm he was
married for like how the [ __ ] did that
more I'll get married I think it's
actually the other way around
he's married that's why he did this [ __ ]
wow you have a bad
and I disagree he wants to have a good
day you shoulda saw the way he said that
does it was like to get out moment like
he was like no I might need help inside
so are you saying you're unhappy in this
marriage is that what you're saying oh I
think tip has more information do you
want to talk outside about it I think it
has a lot of information I think we're
tired of interrupts I don't want to
interrupt if so then are you happy in
this marriage or what also it depends on
if it's a 747 or 70 that some have a
buttons
well you're pushing all of these buttons
[Laughter]
might be vide minutes early yeah I think
it's a pretty pretty clear of what
happened here what happened you let us
know well you know Bart might be kind of
right but to get him off the hook I'm
just gonna say that maybe he was going
through some [ __ ] in his marriage and
then he couldn't take it anymore so he
decided to crash the plane what did you
said nothing different than but what
parts I know but I'm trying to get the
attention off him so you guys don't
fight it therefore reminded me of pissed
no no but it's okay because I I'm saying
it mad at him I say you could get mad at
me I'm the one that's saying I can't get
mad I'm not married so I could say this
that's true I can't believe you've now
got someone who wasn't married now he's
afraid of marriage because he thinks
it's gonna cause him to crash a [ __ ]
plane
I'm not afraid cause of that I already
know it's gonna happen so I know I know
what to prepare for clench my butthole
but for this case yeah Bracy for
marriage is like bracing for impact
right yeah I'm saying yeah you know
what's gonna happen both sides this is
like the billionth date you left your
ring at home where's the ring
is happening in this video guys know his
speakers are big of IQ it's all nothing
at all true every day I see it I was
gonna pass them but it's gonna stay on
there he doesn't want me there today no
he did tell me this morning that he did
tell me this morning that he was fixing
things around the house for writing this
thing he left it at the polisher a lot
of the party didn't even have it on
yesterday well I was fixing things
around the house now if you put it in
the case I know the case that snaps
closed you put it in that kitchen took
it to the postures Parkinson it was in
the ring holder on his desk
oh yeah the replica is to keep a
negative replica that's what you saw the
replica hmm so a replica I'm so glad
it's gonna be nice and shiny then honey
I'm getting it blessed by like some
crystal ladies and gentlemen yeah to
keep married to marriage strong he said
that the chakra energy within the chakra
it disappeared
it's hot like chalk yeah it was fading
the lady said they were spiritually
fading so I'm gonna really need it to
recharge it wind bless this guy keep
side busking I know he's the homie
trying to help you guys he's trying to
prevent me and Steve from distilling
planes and crashing them look talk about
Chuck now you bailed me out I got you
what kind of chalk do you like blue
chalk blue I like blue - I like pink
I like wooden used to [ __ ] do
graffiti on the asphalt you know it's
like a gateway the sidewalk chalk the
big baby
I like sidewalk chalk yeah but I love
sidewalk what starts you ever dude I
walk talking jail gateway graffiti Jeff
design lock chalk yeah yeah it's fine
talk is always better than a failed
marriage on that's all I gotta say
oh you brought it back Belle marriage
you could chalk it up to the wife I
guess you are doing so good but it's
coming from me so it's okay right God
don't get a divorce guys [ __ ] damn II
went there huh
yeah well all I can tell you though is
this airplane stealin the business of
airplane stealing
yeah people a lot of people are [ __ ]
pissed because they're like post 9/11
like everyone has to get checked and
like they make it hard to just get
through TSA and then this happens we
were there people on the plane there
were no few okay that's who left the
keys on the plane there are no keys we
just fly them no it's just the five
buttons in the yeah thought you were the
expert yeah I know how to fly them by
never owned actual pair of airplane keys
cuz I don't know there's no key you said
there's no button why is there no keys
that's crazy to me yeah it's like a fob
just got the pilots fob and just walk in
and yeah that was suck if the pilot left
their keys in the hotel today be tight
ah somebody called the Radisson in
ground control can we get a locksmith or
he locks it in the plane can I get your
pal a to come and unlock my keys and the
bus the [ __ ] door open what does it
look like it looks like I'm jerking a
big horse dick is that what you want
that's what she wants so part one's yeah
that's what I wanted I don't want Steve
to do it
[Music]